bonsoir un rémy chabot merci de répondre
à nos questions ce soir sur arte france
vous invoquer le droit à la vie et le
droit au respect de la vie privée et
familiale finalement votre requête est
rejetée vous vous y attendiez
alors petit rectificatif elle n'est pas
tout à fait rejeter c'est uniquement
l'article 39 du règlement intérieur de
la série d achat la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme qui stipule qu alors
cet article 39 c'est important de se
situer dans le contexte c'est
l'équivalent du référé en france
c'est l'équivalent dans des situations
qui doivent être traitées en urgence et
là c'est le dh qui était dans sa
composition réunis avec cette juge
aujourd'hui à juger en fait
l'obligation n'a pas jugé l'obligation
vaccinale ni c'est le caractère urgent
de la situation qui a été rejetée en
revanche tout le dossier va rester
aujourd'hui
traiter jusqu au 22 septembre ce que
c'est le délai qu'on nous a données pour
amener les éléments complets en seo dh
donc c'est uniquement le caractère
urgent de la situation donc l'article 39
du règlement intérieur de la cee dh qui
a été rejetée c'est important de le
préciser tu es mais d'ici là d'ici à la
date butoir qui on venait d'annoncer qu
est ce qui va se passer
alors écoutez c'est simple on a des
échéances si on avait saisi la cdh comme
vous l'avez dit en préambule avec ce
caractère d'urgence donc l'article le
fameux article 39 c'est bien parce que
le 15 septembre les sapeurs pompiers se
retrouveront dans une situation en tout
cas pour ceux qui ne souhaitent pas être
vaccinés avec une situation qui est pour
nous dangereuse dans le sens où il ya
une une perte donc de leur emploi et
même si elle est provisoire et une perte
de rémunération
je souhaiterais rappeler que dans notre
requête était toujours en cours notre
demande attaque l article 12 et 14 de la
loi du 5 août 2021 et en fait on nous
demandions la suspension de l'obligation
vaccinale telle qu'elle était inscrite
dans la loi nous deux dion également
l'interdiction
la suppression pardon de l'interdiction
d'exercer leur activité
opposés aux personnes n'ayant pas
satisfait à l'obligation vaccinale et
puis forcément nous demandions également
la suppression de cette mention qui
prévoyait l'interruption du versement de
la rémunération
des personnels soumis à la vaccination
obligatoire
vous attendez dans la décision de la
cedeao au global puisque là on a parlé
du fameux article 39 lorsque la décision
sera rendue complètement à quoi est ce
que vous attendez concrètement
être très concrètement ce que nous
souhaitons c'est que il ya un état
d'urgence sanitaire qui est fixée au 15
novembre entre le 15 septembre date à
laquelle les sapeurs-pompiers et les
soignants 1 c'est la seule les seuls
corporation acquis aujourd'hui la
vaccination est imposé
peut-être d'autres pointent le bout de
leur nez mais ce que nous souhaitons
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on laisse le temps
surtout que les
les franges de sapeurs-pompiers vacciner
aujourd'hui sont très très large on
avoisine les 65 à 70% des sapeurs
pompiers tous statuts confondus 1
professionnelle volontaire et militaires
qui sont aujourd'hui vaccinés ou alors
en
a qui ont bien pas dans leur parcours au
vaccinale donc la bonne question à poser
c'est pourquoi les sapeurs pompiers se
font pas vacciner c'est vraiment un
épiphénomène c'est une quinzaine
vingtaine de sapeurs pompiers par par
département mais il faut respecter leur
choix et les accompagner et peut-être
que d'autres principes sont en cours
d'élaboration
on le voit bien et je vais pas les citer
aujourd'hui et des laboratoires
en fin d'année une sortie de vaccination
qui serait peut-être plus en adéquation
et en accord avec les sapeurs-pompiers
qui sont aujourd'hui récalcitrants mais
vous vous dites que le vaccin vous
n'êtes pas content le vaccin mais contre
l'obligation vaccinale c'est quoi la
différence exactement la différence elle
est simple c'est que vous avez des
sapeurs-pompiers et des soignants
infirmières qui sont peut-être la
population professionnelle la plus
protégée qui a dans ce pays
nous portant des masques et charlotte et
des sur bottes et et lunettes pour
chaque intervention donc moi je
réellement s'il ya une population une
confession même passer à travers les les
masques des gants les charlottes n'y a
pas de barrière vous avez mais vous avez
tout à fait raison mais la bonne
question alors si allons au bout du
raisonnement c'est que toutes les
corporations qui sont au contact du
public avec nous sur le terrain si cette
si cette mesure est bienveillante
vis-à-vis des police des pompiers et des
infirmières il faut imaginer qu'elle
soit bienveillante également vis-à-vis
des services de police donc c'est la
mesure donc c'est le deux poids deux
mesures que vous dénoncez nous dénonçons
le deux poids deux mesures et nous
souhaitons également que ce soit pas une
mesure coercitive cette vaccination
aujourd'hui
nécessite plutôt des explications et un
accompagnement plutôt que virer des
sapeurs-pompiers et des infirmières qui
a été applaudi à peine un nom dans les
pas du conte
un préavis de grève nationale illimitée
a été lancée lundi ce mouvement est il
suivit va-t-il lettre
et est-ce que vous exercez quand même
votre métier malgré cette grève
alors le but de cette grève qui a été
déposé ce préavis de grève n'est pas du
tout de mettre en échec les secours dans
les dix absolument pas n'est pas non
plus de montrer les gros bras en pouvant
invoquer 80 90 % de grévistes ce ne sera
pas le cas le but est uniquement en de
permettre aux pompiers qui à compter du
15 septembre puisque nous souhaitions
une décision de la ce et des
achats-ventes 15 septembre qui
permettrait justement sapeurs-pompiers
de pouvoir poursuivre leur activité
professionnelle
mais là au 15 septembre on nous avons
précisément 721 sapeurs pompiers sur
l'ensemble du territoire sur 56
départements qui ne pourront plus
exercer leur profession ou leur activité
et cette greffe permet aux sapeurs
pompiers donc ces personnels là de
pouvoir être absent du service sans être
sous le coup d'une suspension
et je vous rappelle juste qu'en le début
juillet c'était le licenciement qui
était prévu dans le projet de loi
initial donc c'est quand même des choses
qui était quand même assez grave et nous
sommes aujourd'hui la seule solution que
nous avons c'est que les sapeurs
pompiers qui ne souhaite pas faire
vacciner puisse se positionner en
position de la ville si vous souhaitez
des chiffres de grévistes on avoue on
avoisinera difficilement 10% de
grévistes sur l'ensemble du territoire
merci à vous d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire national du syndicat sud se
disent service départemental d'incendié
et de secours